et là attention interview à brac dame
josiane balasko qu'elle dépôt doit avoir
un homme pour vous séduire
à part le priapisme qui rappelons le est
une maladie par un défaut un bon lavage
toi c'est toi c'est dur non mais aussi
les ambésiens cicta dénicher un journal
et violente qu'à défaut d'avoir un an
pourrait séduire
avant d'être un peu fragile ah bah voilà
quelle est l'insulté qui vous a fait le
plus plaisir
après je suis très très vulgaire lé
phénomène allemand du lierre quel est le
core i7 et quoi je suis simplement une
insulte non mais emmanuel ce soir c'est
ce qui fait plaisir contre la [ __ ] qui
se baignent à poil
bon sang
les gens s'ils ne sont pas choqués par
la tenue mais par l'horaire c'est
beaucoup trop tôt quel est le compliment
qui vous énerve le plus fait mémoire
phénoménale temps des journées comment
ils font pour apprendre tout ça quelle
mémoire
quelle mémoire oui moi c'est moi quand
je vais voir des comédiens sur scène au
théâtre je leur dis mais comment on fait
pour apprendre tout ce qui est pour moi
comme je sais qu est ce que vous
voudriez que vos enfants ratent leur bac
ça ça m'est égal de menthe et leurs bas
coin contraire de toi à maman ne peuvent
rentrer dans leur test hiv c'est bien
d'apprendre alors que leur interdisez
vous à vos enfants que vous ne vous
interdisez pas quand tu étais plus
petits dire des mots grossiers
moi j'ai un droit ou pas voilà les
pétards aussi j'imagine c'est difficile
difficile icd a toujours dans les temps
mais pas toujours derrière parce qu'on
aura les sylphes humilié ne pas le faire
sous votre nez c'est vrai pour quelles
raisons seriez vous capable de refuser
votre plus belle histoire d'amour pour
des raisons fiscales
quel est le film à succès que vous êtes
contente d'avoir refusé ou pas les 10 à
6,6 ici non mais j'ai appris à dire j'ai
pas refusé de filmer la vie celui auquel
tu pensais quand ad je peux pas l'aider
à le dire non soumis à prescription
maintenant je sais à quoi tu pensais
encore un couple pas un montage en son
nom mais en plus j'ai pas vu non non je
peux pas dire tellement raison que j'ai
pas j'ai pas vu des films que je refuse
que j'ai pas forcément voir plusieurs le
mien par exemple un mais on ne tient
jamais tu m'a même pas tu m'as demandé
mais j'étais en train de bosser 8
assists pas le problème de laurence
c'est qu'il n'insiste pas tous italiens
paypal pour les enfants tu as un site
insiste patin je veux pas là il apparaît
doit il faut insister dans ce métier si
tu veux réussir tahiti est couché non
violente en sus le rend si au début
début tu coucher quand ouais ouais
arrêter toujours de dos c'est chiant on
voit que les gens
alors
et la question du pompage composent ça
vous fait a fait dix minutes vous posez
des questions qu'il faudrait pas bon
m